[Music]
this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host my co-host
today ramsay personality number one
best-selling author
anthony o'neil host of the ever-popular
youtube show exploding called the table
the table's not exploding but the
popularity is so uh you can check him
out there on youtube anytime
and of course check out his uh advice
here today
on the air if you want to talk to us the
call is free and some say the advice is
worth exactly what you pay for it
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five victor is in dallas hi
victor how are you hey my man i'm doing
good how about yourself
better than i deserve how can we help
so i have a fourteen thousand dollar
um debt remaining on my car finance via
ford
and i could sell it today for about
twenty two thousand dollars
um and just keep the cash and use that
to buy another car and have a little bit
of money left over
um me and my wife are both in grad
school so we're cash flowing that and
just paying that
um out of pocket so that extra money
could be helpful the complicating factor
is that i don't actually pay the monthly
note on my car my dad pays it for me
every month and it's been like three
years and he's never missed a payment so
he's really good with it
um so i'm not actually like spending
that money but the car is in my name
and i think that's it uh what do you
guys make what's your household income
so we make about 42 000 when will you
graduate from grad school
so i'll be done in
next year i don't know whether it's
going to be in the summer or in the fall
it kind of just depends on how much
course that i can handle but i'll be
done
next year for sure and just don't know
what semester
and my wife has about another two years
probably
and we're both in seminary she's doing
counseling to be an lpc
and i'm just getting like a general
theology degree um for the password and
that kind of stuff
[Music]
okay sell it yeah
yeah now when you sell it have a
conversation with your dad and make sure
that he's not going to want
part um some of the proceeds
oh no he i talked to him already he's
like hey if you sell it
you can keep all the cash and i'll send
you whatever i would pay
for the car to you just in cash as a
gift to like help pay for school
um so he said he would give me that and
we'll have that in our pocket as well
i like your dad how much how much is
your car payment
um my car payment is maybe like 430 i
don't actually know i've never made the
payment
but it's somewhere between four and 500
it's like a 2018 mustang yeah
so okay here's here's what i'm basing
that on
your income is low for someone driving a
22 000
car and it's going to stay low for a
while
if you told me you were getting ready to
graduate in the fall well everything's
getting ready to change then we're not
going to make a decision based on what's
happening today because it's going to
change real soon
but it sounds like you've got a couple
more years of this and not having this
around your neck
or your dad's neck or anything else
would be really handy so the rule of
thumb is don't have too much
invested even if it's paid for in things
that are going down
in value one definition of too much
invested is anything with wheels and
motors added together
equaling more than half your annual
income is generally too much invested so
if you make fifty thousand dollars a
year you buy a thirty thousand dollar
boat
that's under the stupid column
okay and you know you make forty
thousand dollars a year you got twenty
two thousand dollar car
now you're not paying it and that you
know and that's nice and all of that
but just getting rid of an asset that's
going the wrong way
while your income stays in the 40s for
the next two years
is a wise thing yeah yeah and he's going
to come out with about 8k
uh dave so i mean i'm buying a five
thousand dollar car cash yeah
five or six something like that and you
know and then the 400 goes in your
budget instead of going to the bank
there you go so
it's almost as if you got rid of a car
payment yeah since your dad is going to
continue to send the money that's
very generous of him i'm with anthony
that's very nice be supporting him
he's proud that he's going into the
seminary yeah and uh
you know trying to be there to help him
and walk with him through the process
and that's good
so as a father dave what would you like
what would you
like to see him do with that four
hundred dollars that he's getting from
his father every month
i think i think the young guy's got a
pretty good handle on his budget already
absolutely he's out of debt i mean he
was there's nothing in here that
indicates he's lacking in frugality
um so i i think he's what do you think i
mean i
i agree with you i mean i'm i'm i'm
pocketing it i'm gonna use it towards
school
yeah it's going in the budget the
monthly budget for food lights water
school
yeah cash flowing school and now we're
four hundred dollars up
i mean if nothing and we don't have
something that we own
that over the next two years while we
drive it's gonna lose eight thousand
dollars in value absolutely
you know which is what happens to these
stinky things they go down like a rock
that's where chevy got that like a rock
but you know what day some of our
listeners saying but dave he's not
paying for it
i know but he is paying for it right
when you take 22 000 and you turned into
12
right that's paying for it yes anytime
you do that you're going the
wrong direction all right tony's with us
tony is in sacramento hi tony how are
you
hey dave thank you so much for taking my
call how you doing there anthony
i'm doing well man thanks for asking so
my question is this
um our parents-in-law had just offered
us to live rent-free in a vacant home
they have
uh owned so they own several properties
and uh
this one is just vacant and they wanted
to us to sell our house
stack that cash that we made on equity
live there rent free
while my wife finishes nursing school
this december
and uh we don't know where we want to be
located yet just because when she gets
done with nursing school we get a better
idea of where we want to like settle
and we know this is not going to be our
forever home so should we take that
offer
it's a tough one for me anything with
what parents and and i get a little
nervous especially when i hear free
i just because i don't want something to
go left and cremit from wrong dave but
if something goes left that they don't
like then they can kick me out
you know so i i'm i'm 50 50 right here
i'm a little nervous
how's your guys relationship it's pretty
good so
um my parents-in-law had helped all of
the other siblings and they just we're
the youngest one now
so they had helped all the other
siblings like they were living written
free also so they're not
they're not like controlling people no
absolutely not they're they're very
helpful i think that's anthony's concern
and that's a valid concern
yeah i'm probably going to take it since
it's a quality relationship with quality
people and
for it's for a short term and your game
plan is you're going to be moving
anyway in six to nine months anyway
right
right correct and so you just pile up
the cash are you guys out of debt
we don't have a debt in the world so i
did oh like when i bought this house
i did close out with her sister-in-law
because i have no credit
just because i never had a credit card
at all so she's under the loan also
that helps get rid of that exactly
exactly
how much money do you have in your
savings account right now tony right now
without selling the home is 40k
oh yeah yeah okay i agree with dave yeah
you're gonna
you know you're just cashing out while
the market's hot and you're gonna put
the money in the bank
for your next move in this next
transition there's nothing wrong with
that there's nothing huge no huge
advantage
basically your monthly payment is your
advantage for six months and
that's that's enough reason to do it as
long as everybody stays on their side of
the fence
good boundaries with the with the
relatives then
this can be okay this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just thirty dollars a month get
unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
new episodes of the table with anthony
o'neil
air every monday how to set a clear
vision for your future everything you
need to know about
success and how you can go from looking
fake rich to really becoming
wealthy a lot of people looking fake
rich hey absolutely and you know what
dave
i think you'll be very proud of me i
know you probably listened to the show
but this week's show is the 10 things
you shouldn't do with your paycheck
and i literally write down verbatim it's
an hour-long show and i literally talk
about
here's what you need to do with every
time you get paid cover your four walls
do this do that
um and the the the the response is
insane i already had 25 000 views in 24
hours
wow because i literally go through the
basics because people want to look rich
when i want to help people hey
here's how you build wealth and it's a
solid foundation so tom stanley wrote
the millionaire next door the last book
he wrote before he passed away
um wrote a book called stop acting rich
there it is and he went through the
statistical and mathematical evidence
that acting rich will actually cause you
to never be rich yes sir
yes pretty intense pretty pretty amazing
well here at ramsey solutions
we want to transform so many lives
that disruption happens to this crazy
culture
this crazy y'all have you all noticed
that this culture is out of control
imagine a world where it's weird to have
a student loan
where most people pay cash for their car
where the credit card is the cigarette
of the financial industry
where you actually understand the
success principles and your kids do too
that anthony teaches every day
where you understand how to get a job
and have a career you love from ken
coleman and it becomes normal
well instead you know we're trying to
put ourselves out of business but
there's no
danger of that if you want to join us on
that crusade we're currently on the hunt
for software
with expertise in ruby rail ruby on
rails so you don't even know what it is
java c-sharp
front-end technologies if you're a ux
designer seo
content marketing specialist a data data
analyst
if you're in the tech world we are
hiring 300 folks this year
and uh ramsey solutions is exploding
and uh not just tech but everything but
a bunch
of high-end tech jobs and here's the
cool thing about tech jobs at ramsey we
work
40 hours not 80.
we actually go home you come out of the
parking lot at 5 30.
oh yes it's empty empty it's empty empty
and we don't ask people that we don't
crack the whip on them and
so forth so text the word work if you're
interested you can
check out dave's hiring tab at ramsey
solutions.com or text work
233 789 work
233 nine because we do
do that during the 40 hours we do we
work
laura is with us laura is in montreal
canada hey
laura how are you good how are you
better than we deserve how can we help
um you're breaking up
try again
hello hello try one more time you're
breaking up
okay no worries um my question i'm
really clueless right now to be honest
um so my parents have an 18-year
age difference and there is
a so obviously recently we've had some
about wills and things like that and um
my family has a cottage it's really
important to us
it's been in our family for generations
and it really means a lot to our
everyone and our family
however um i was speaking to my mom who
doesn't uh she doesn't have a job and
she
expressed that she would be interested
in selling it
after god forbid the passing of my
father
especially if she needed money and i'm
really wondering
what is the what right as a child do you
have to interfere in that
none not zero it's not your stuff
yeah why do you think you do laura
i don't know it's just so hard seeing
something that meant so much
to everyone in our family possibly
not you know being in our family how
much is it worth
a lot um it's just done a really good
piece of land for probably upwards to a
million
well why don't you sell some of the land
and keep the cottage
wouldn't but would i be able to suggest
that or is that well you could buy the
cottage
and ask them to carve out just a few
acres and keep the cottage itself
because it's not the farm that means
something to you it was the it was the
lake part of it right
yeah it's just generally having even a
piece of it you know just the
just the memories that are attached to
the the area
i guess that is a good idea it's just
rough it's hard to
like i have offered to even like give
support if needed
like i would be fine giving financial
support obviously to my family
how old are you i'm 26.
okay what do you make um just under 70.
that's great all right and uh your dad
is how old
um my dad is in his mid-60s now
okay all right well uh let's pretend you
got 20 years
before this really comes up he gets to
his mid-80s okay
that would give you time to prepare if
this means a lot to you to build some
wealth and be able to offer to buy it
yeah and it would be certainly okay for
you to ask
that you be given the option to buy it
in the will
should they give that you'd be given
first route of refusal or a
an option to purchase it uh first option
to purchase it or something like that so
that they didn't just call you up one
day and go we sold it
you know instead you got you you know if
because you'd saved up a half million
dollars and you could have bought half
the property and
uh had them sell off the other half or
something like that and
that would have scratched your itch and
then you then at that point you become a
customer of the estate
not someone who just feels entitled to
it agreed
i agree yeah just have the conversation
but i wouldn't go in there saying hey
this is what i want this is what needs
to be done
just ask you don't have any rights yeah
you're not entitled to anything
i'm sorry it hurts your feelings i
understand that and it doesn't mean a
lot to you emotionally i hear you saying
that
but that doesn't give you any moral or
legal or even emotional rights to it
um we have a lake house and if i decide
to sell it tomorrow uh
it will break my kids heart because
they've all learned to ski there the
grand babies have all spent time there
we all love it
it's the same kind of a thing it's an
emotional piece of property for us
it'll break my heart anthony anthony
anthony's anthony would be crying he's
already his eyes are already leaking i'm
serious
that's where you learned to ski exactly
there hey he did he's quite
a water skier now you should have seen
him the falls were amazing last weekend
but the uh
anyway the uh uh yeah that that the
point being
uh you know you earn the right to speak
into this by having some money to do
something it's not just a matter of
offering support it's a matter of
hey if you ever gonna sell it i don't
want that to happen because i love it so
much
please give me first rights and would
you mind even putting that in the will
dad
um and something like that that would be
okay and there's nothing wrong with that
at all and so i got dibs on that
you know that that's a if if you're
gonna if you would allow me to i would
consider that awesome because it means
so much
to me but just because it was your
childhood
uh summer vacation and it's emotional
does not give you any rights
you're not you have zero entitlement on
that sorry josh is that's my opinion and
you asked it josh is in dallas hey josh
how are you
sorry to talk to you dave i have a
question about trading in my vehicle
so i purchased a um a brand new truck
november last year and traded in my
truck
um the dealership contacted me a couple
weeks ago or last week
and they're wanting to buy my truck back
with the shortage of vehicles
so o26 on it right now
i made a really good trade on it and got
a lot of equity in it and i owe 26 not
one offer me 41 000 in cash right now
would you pay for it i uh i paid like
42.5
wow yeah yep
uh what is it worth yeah what does kelly
buble says
says um that's why i did a online
kelly blue book trading and um it was it
said that it was worth
40 but then whenever i went and talked
to the dealership they said they would
give me 41.
yeah and that's trade-in by the way
that's not private sales so
i think yeah i think you'd probably get
i think you could push them get a little
more out of it do you want to sell it
um well here's the thing so my wife and
i took on some debt
from a child custody case of fourteen
thousand dollars from a
attorney fees so we're working on paying
that off um
what's your household income 140
okay i'm okay if you sell it it's
certainly a good opportunity if you want
to get out
this is like getting out while the
getting's good uh and you probably get
more for it if you lean on them just a
little bit because you do obviously have
a vehicle wow you can sell it
but you six months later how weird is
that
highly unusual
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
jeffrey and megan are with us hey guys
how are you hi we're great i agree
welcome where do you guys live lee's
summit missouri
lee's summit kansas city area that's
where my daughter-in-law is from
awesome good for you guys welcome to
nashville
and all the way down here to do a debt
free screen yep
cool how much of you guys paid off one
hundred thousand
six stop one hundred six thousand eighty
6180
and 44 cents good how long did this take
two years two months and 10 days all
right
and your range of income during that
time is 102
000 to 130 000 good what do you guys do
for a living
i'm a medical laboratory scientist and
i'm a clinical manager for a residential
behavioral health facility
oh great okay cool what kind of debt was
this
about half was my student loans
um and then we had uh my car
and then credit cards ah you were kind
of normal
scary normal sucks but you were there
lots of debt a hundred and
six thousand were the car credit cards
and student loans that's a lot
that's a whole lot yeah so what happened
two years and two months ago that got
you started on this journey
so our church had um started offering
fpu
and i'm actually the nerd and was kind
of like oh i think we need to do it but
i never
pushed for it and then megan was
actually like we're doing this
oh that's good
so megan what push what made you decide
to push for that you know i think it was
really
when you're close to maxing out a credit
card that has a
20 000 limit every month you've got a
problem
and as a counselor the first step to
change is admitting that you have a
problem hey man
a little bit of my own advice amen yeah
that's exactly right that is by far the
first step
as a matter of fact uh you've almost
solved a problem once you admit that
there is one
because everything else will just happen
after that yeah once you say oh this
has got to stop yeah so then the class
pops up at just the right time at your
church
and you jump into financial peace
university both of you together
and uh so how far into the class were
you before you kind of went
i think we really can fix this like
probably the third week and it's
actually kind of interesting
megan had gone shopping at walmart and
she had her cash envelopes
but didn't have enough cash so
she grabbed for a credit card
and that evening uh during our class we
cut that puppy out
ah so that was the debt lesson that was
the debt lesson that was the plastic
surgery
yeah and at the end of class everybody
chops up their credit cards
[Laughter]
well that was perfect timing yeah one
last hurrah at a walmart
chop chop i love it plastic surgery very
good you guys
i love it good so throughout this
journey two years that's a that's
i mean that's that's a long time let's
be honest um what was the hardest thing
outside of cutting up the credit cards i
see her face right now but
outside of that what was hard throughout
this journey you know i
i think for me um
it was just
really learning to live within my limits
like setting limits for myself and
i'm the free spirit i'm the one who
likes to go shopping on the weekends i
like to go do things
um but learning to be more intentional
and
you know we didn't you know we we set a
recreation budget so that we weren't
driving each other crazy and we set a
date budget so we still have that time
protected
um and just making good use of
the funds that we had it's awesome
that is awesome now you with you being
the nerd what was hard for you
because it seems like you actually
enjoyed this process once you started
i did the hardest part was actually
starting
i had a very good 100 match
on my 401k up to 10
[Music]
i actually had to convince him that i'm
like no look at dave's math it works you
have to
we have to stop this he ran the numbers
himself and he's like oh it actually
would work
that's a nerd for you i love it that's
fun that's exactly what i would have
done brother
all right so uh what do you tell people
the key is now you've done it you've
gotten out of debt
what's the secret to getting out of debt
no credit cards
all right also in that same vein i mean
it's the patent answer that everyone
gives but the budget
yeah it sets the budget it sets the
limits for
you spin this well it's the map to
florida if you want to drive to florida
you need a map
you know it's the gps it shows you where
to go and get on you know
turn here don't turn here oops you
missed it keep going you know whatever i
mean
that's what you need with a budget you
got to have a guideline and you don't
get to your destination if you don't
have a map
and that's all it is it's that's why
everybody says it because it works
it's it is the key element that we do
see in people that are successful
because as you said earlier megan it's
the intentionality but in this case it's
intentionality on paper
and that's really all a budget is i'm
curious uh now that you're out of debt
what's next well um as part of our
journey
jeff was commuting an hour each way to
work
so we made the move from a rural county
south of kansas city to the metro area
so we're renting now so we that total
doesn't include selling our house
so we sold the house that we had we're
renting now so now we're
trying to plow through three and three
steps three and three b
yeah there you go all right get the down
payment so if you get another property
yeah yeah good for you guys so well done
well done so uh you brought your kiddo
with you what's your name and age
bethany age six bethany is six years old
so was she participating in all of this
process
she well kind of um you know she's
gotten
a little bit older in this um she she
has her own chores and her own
money that she gets to earn and so we're
trying to help her
learn how to do that cool way to go
bethany good job
well we've got a copy of the legacy
journey for you that is the next
chapter in your story as you move on and
change her family tree and leave a
legacy well done you guys very proud of
you thank you congratulations
very very neat job i love it also a copy
of the total money makeover an extra one
for you to give away so you can pay it
forward and
get somebody else moving on this journey
so we can keep spreading the good word
out here on how to get out of debt and
how to become wealthy
well done jeffrey megan and bethany from
kansas city 106
000 paid off in two years in two months
making 102 to 130. count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one
[Applause]
you can tell she was counting she was
counting a lot louder than her parents
i love it good for you well done man
that is awesome
you know they moved they got new
information and they acted on it
yeah yeah a hundred and six thousand
dollars of credit cards
yeah credit cards credit cards we just
don't
trash credit cards often enough on this
show we really don't we should trash
them more
you know so they had plastic surgery and
they didn't say
oh i get airline miles oh i get i get
discover points oh and they did they
didn't start talking
broke people talk uh-oh because rich
people don't say that stuff
come on dave that's what broke people
say i know i'm ready to point card for
an emergency
that's just broke people talk oh you
just made some people upset dave that's
my
spiritual gift i am talented
at that my goal because some of the best
things that have happened to me in my
life are when i got pissed off
and i had to go prove somebody wrong and
i was wrong yes so cause i'm not wrong
on this one and so if you're pissed off
because you're one of those little
hanging and
gaining mileage like like you're ever
going to use that mouse have you ever
tried to use the miles or the airline
freaking jupiter has to be aligned with
mars i mean there's so many guidelines
and setbacks and no ways to do it and
you know what she said
trick to getting out of that yep cut
them up cut them up cut them up cut them
up and after you cut them up get
intentional
about getting out of debt yeah bottom
line yeah otherwise you're a rat chasing
its tail man you just go go
go go go go go nothing happens nothing
happens except you're making mastercard
and
bank of america oh make me want i just
gotta throw up in my mouth
bank of america oh gross
gross and make them rich
we'll make them rich they're already
rich why are you giving them your money
in the name of airline knives it's just
straight up stupid
hope i wasn't unclear this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five colton is with us in
iowa city hi colton how are you
hey dave i'm well thanks for asking that
by yourself better than i deserve sir
how can we help
good uh yeah so my wife and i have been
struggling uh maritally
lately we've been married uh will be six
years this august and the fifth year has
been rough
uh one of the areas of stress are our
finances
uh we're in need of rebuilding uh
foundations really
we have a starter emergency fund um
about thirty two thousand dollars in
debt a mortgage
and uh income that's not always
predictable
um so i've got some specific questions
for you but first i
just want to know like what do you
recommend to rebuild financial
foundations in our marriage
[Music]
well i
i think everybody has to have a voice in
the discussion
and uh sometimes that's what happens and
then the second thing that
that if everybody has a voice the voice
has to involve
um that as i use my my vote
in our marriage that my vote is not for
my selfish need or want my vote is for
the good
of the overall family that's how i'm
using my vote
and so it's not like a little child in
other words stomping their feet
with a red face on the cereal aisle
demanding
frosted flakes because i deserve them
and sometimes we get that little kid
inside of us
making our adult decisions called
selfishness
and then it affects our relationships so
couples that can
rise up above their own selfish desires
for the good of the overall family will
ultimately get their own selfish desires
uh but they also get unity then
and because there's some nobility to
that but the most most of the money
fights that sharon and i have had
uh involve selfishness on one of our
parts
usually mine
does that make any sense oh yeah
absolutely i just
i i got a a new craving for a new car
and that's been uh not so good for us
and so i totally get that
yeah so that kind of explains you know
what's going on with you that's not a
bad thing that you want a new car
the bad thing is if you actually acted
on that
while you're 32 000 in debt and your
wife's scared to death
because she's worried with the erratic
income all the time
if you're going to have money for
electricity
and you come waltzing in with your muddy
boots going i just bought a new car
because i'm just the smartest guy on the
planet and she's going to slit your
throat you know that's what's going to
happen right
so that's that's what goes down you get
you just get angry
at that stuff but so you have to say hey
i'm going to get a new car
but the way i'm going to get it is i'm
going to live like no one else so that
later
i can live like no one else because i
got to clean this 32 000 up for the good
of myself and to go this family
before i can even talk about a car yeah
i'm curious colin now what's the family
uh
household income
uh yeah so it is she brings home
probably around uh
2800 a month that's uh after tax
um and then for for me i'm a worship
leader at a church
as well as a wedding filmmaker so that
is
super sporadic um making fifteen dollars
an hour
um at the church so it sounds like about
40.
about 40 grand a year yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so i could see i could
depending on how many weddings that we
booked
because if we book weddings i can make
40 000 myself
with just uh uh 15 or so weddings so
what does
a typical case study fight look like in
your house
describe it to me about money a money
fight
yeah typical uh fight i guess would be
i want to do one thing and she wants to
do
something else with money so for example
i want to say
invest a little bit of money and she
don't want to do that she want to
want to be rigid and pay off debt or i
want to pay off a debt but she's afraid
of
not having enough money for next month
um
and so a lot of it's uh pretty passive
um
passive aggressiveness uh we're not
really like
vocal at each other like that but um
yeah it can lead to some tension yeah
okay so
that's where uh the way if you'll start
doing a
detailed budget where every dollar
of your income for this coming month
has a name on paper has an assignment on
paper
and you agree on where it's going to go
and you're applying any extra money you
can find in the budget to the baby steps
and both of you are in agreement on that
concept
then what happens is all you're holding
each other accountable to
is what you agreed to and
that we're sticking to the baby steps
and what here's
here's exactly how this will go down the
first month
the first time you do a detailed budget
where every
dollar has a name it's going to be a big
fight
get ready you may need to actually stop
midway through working on the budget and
have a cooling off period and both of
you go for a walk around the block
separately because it's going to drag up
all this stuff
okay it's going to drag up all these
insecurities it's going to drag up all
these uh
feelings of inadequacy where maybe i
don't feel like i'm making enough money
or doing enough
it's gonna it's gonna drag up a little
selfish kid that's in the cereal aisle
all this stuff is gonna come up but if
you can push all of that down
onto that paper and say the best way
for me to have the life i want which is
for my family to succeed
is to follow these steps and have a game
plan for the money
the best way for me to have security is
to follow these steps
then you're going to begin to get the
emotions under control the second month
you'll have there'll be some rough spots
in the discussion the third time you do
the budget the third month it'll
actually start to work
but i'm going to promise you some pain
between now and the third month
and and correct me from wrong dave
because i'm not married but i i
from a money perspective colton i would
suggest to help you
kind of ease that pain a little bit
maybe you and your wife talk about what
does success
look like for us five ten years from now
what is our vision what are we
aiming for is it to be debt-free is it
to buy a home
is it to go on a dream vacation is it to
build wealth and then once you
identify that success that vision then
the budget helps you get to that
then the budget and we'll be like all
right is this gonna
if me buying a new car or it's me doing
this is that helping us get towards
the next five to ten years and if you're
following the baby steps
you don't have to have a discussion
about whether to do investing or to do
debt you have debt we're working on the
debt there you go so we've both
submitted ourselves to this proven plan
yep and so all i got to do is go
no it's not what the baby steps are
because we've agreed we were going to do
this
oh i guess darn it that's right so the
best way to get to investing
is to get out of debt for the best way
to uh get out of debt is temporarily
stop investing and so
the there's a reason the baby steps are
laid out the way they are the reason
millions tens of millions of people have
done this now literally yeah that's not
an exaggeration
and so you just say all right i'm gonna
do this plan that has worked for so many
others we are going to do the plan we're
both in agreement that we're going to do
this plan
it's not like i'm going to do it make
you do it we're both in agreement
and then when that feeling rises up and
she says hey i feel insecure
i really want to start investing the
best way for us to get investing is get
this debt cleared let's keep hammering
the debt there you go okay or
you know i really want to or you're
thinking man i want to get a new car
well the best way to do that is get
clear of all this stuff
and have some wealth uh because you know
right now you're too broke to be buying
a car you know
and so you know you all of a sudden it
all starts to come
very very clear and you know some of
your vision can be
little things i'll give an example when
we were broke
i clearly remember sharing and i arguing
about the food
budget how much she was going to spend
at the grocery store
and she was mad i mean she because she
wanted more food
like yeah because i was not i was not
being forthcoming enough on that line
item
okay and she was she was hot you know
what sharon looks like she gets that
little
oh yeah it's a head just [ __ ] a little
bit yeah
and so you i mean you can see it coming
right and she says you know someday
sarcastically like he said passive
aggressive i just hope we're rich enough
that i can just go to the grocery store
and just fill up the basket
and i said you know what the best way
for us to get there is to stick the
dadgum budget hey
and you know what today she will tell
you that story today she remembers that
fight
too are you serious because she says
sometimes i just go and fill up the
basket even though we don't need food
just because by god i can do it now
because we paid the price we lived like
no one else now and you fill up the
basket
like no one is no so maybe your vision
is something just like that yeah
absolutely
what was that that was a sign of her
insecurity because i had screwed up and
lost everything and she scared her
family's gonna be hungry yeah that's
what all that meant
yeah it was passive aggressive as crud
is what it was
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
[Music]
thermsyshow.com
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's
the ramsey show where debt is dumb cash
is king and the paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol
of choice i'm dave ramsey your host
anthony o'neil ramsey personality number
one best-selling author
of the book debt free degree yes you can
go to college
debt free and he can show you how he's
my co-host today
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five
two two five kristen is with us kristen
is
in alberta hi kristin how are you
not too bad how are you good how can we
help
uh so i have a question um i bought a
mobile home about two years ago
and i did a bunch of indoor repairs
and uh put probably about 20 grand into
it uh
however i wasn't marked about my
choice in renovating so i ended up
maxing out my visa and my line of credit
um doing the renovations and then i've
been living off of my line of credit
for bills and food and everything else
since then since the spending got a
little bit away from me
and i wasn't thinking about
some of those things going into buying
the place
so i've been putting everything i have
extra into my visa my line of credit to
try and keep
my minimum payments low and
it's been about two years and i came
across you
in november so i started your baby steps
and i have 1500 in my savings
for the emergency fund and then i'm
working on baby steps
too so i've seen
finally now probably three months in a
decrease
in my visa as i'm working on that with
the
higher interest rate and i've
run into some more renovations and
repairs that i have to do
due to the trailer park so my question
is
is it smart for me to just do what i
need to do to the trailer park
and sell the trailer it was a
foreclosure when i bought it
so i'm most likely going to make money
off of it still
i just don't know if it's wise of me to
continue working on the baby steps
and uh pay off my debt and then we're
going towards paying my money
home off or if i should just sell so how
much on your credit how much do you owe
on your credit card
uh so my credit card i'm at 7 100. and
how much do you owe on the trailer
uh 42 000. and what do you make a year
uh so i just went up to about 27 dollars
an hour
and i get paid about 80 hours every two
weeks
okay and i'm just it's just me that owns
it i'm 25.
and what can you sell the trailer for uh
so if i finish doing the outdoor repairs
i could probably put it up for about 80
000.
really yeah uh i got a really good
deal um we've put in really
yeah yeah i got a really really good
deal
um on this foreclosure so you can really
sell
a trailer that's used that you've done a
bunch of repairs to
for eighty thousand dollars in edmonton
alberta just the trailer
yes is there land with it uh sorry
is there land with it uh
no it's in a mobile home uh trailer park
that's hard that's hard have you i hope
you're right
yeah me too have you gotten perfect i
don't think you are but i hope you're
right
have you got an expert to give you the
number
so i actually brought in the realtor who
sold me the trailer when i originally
bought it
um it had been up for 75 000 and then i
bought it for 50. and since then we
we installed shutoff valves we've done
repairs to the furnace
exploring electrical all that and so
when she came
in uh there was a few things but okay
well
yeah i finished up listen if you can get
if you can get that
or a lot less sell it okay
yes and you wanna know why
uh why is that because what do you think
an 80 000
trailer let's just pretend it's worth
that because you you think it is and i
really don't have a good basis for
arguing with you other than i'm shocked
but um let's just pretend it's an 8 000
trailer what's it worth in 10 years
uh i'm going to say probably half the
price tada
goodbye trailer yeah it's not a good
long-term plan
it turns out it turns out to have been a
genius short-term plan
if you take 42 and double it into 80 i'm
gonna just smile for you and
cheer you on and say way to go you are
the luckiest trailer buyer i've ever met
and way to go you killed it and if you
can get that 80 out of there you get it
out there and you run as fast as you can
go
okay if you can get 60 out of there
tomorrow as is
take it and go yeah and that's what she
said i could put it up for
given i do the repairs that i'm also
told to do with the trailer park
yeah how much are those going to cost uh
i'm trying to do it on a budget and so
i'm doing all of the repairs myself
and how much is that going to cost uh
well skirting and
hand railing and fence and deck and how
much is that going to cost
i'm not too sure i'm new to this so
i know when i did renovations before the
spending got away and i didn't plan
yeah that's what i'm afraid of here if
you can take 65 as is and sell it by the
weekend sell it
okay because yeah between my line of
credit my visa i'm sitting up at about
60 000
the good news is you're going to make
money and you're going to get rid of the
stupid visa
bill of 41 7 100 and you're going to get
rid of a trailer that's going down in
value
okay that's the good news it's not a
good long-term plan to fix this and hold
it
yeah the hassle of working on this and
running up debt working on it has not
been a blessing to you it stressed you
out am i right
oh for sure yeah and you're going to
turn 80 000 into 40
if you keep it 10 years there's
no reason to stay in this deal kiddo
zero get out while the getting is good
yeah apparently you've made a good deal
yeah at least with the numbers you
believe are true and i sure hope you're
right highly unusual i'll tell you that
and it sounds like dave what she's
trying to do is put
more money into get to 80. no yeah i
know but i sell it for 65 like it is
exactly and don't be out there building
a deck yeah in a trailer park no
get out of there yeah and you got your
money out
and you and go get you an apartment and
you got rid of your visa and
and then just you know then start
working your baby steps from a simple
inexpensive rental and build your life
out that way
and you don't have any debt and you're
doing really really good then
that's going to be the way to go so
uh those of you in the mobile helm
industry i'm not mad at you
uh but those of you that have bought one
know that they go
one direction when it comes to value
down
they depreciate they're a car you sleep
in
that's what they are this is not a home
well it's inexpensive it's affordable
when you lose half of the value it takes
away all the affordability crap that you
think you believe
this is not a play buy things that go up
in value to live in
simple rule this is the ramsey show
[Music]
uh
still on baby step number one huh how'd
you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org budget
don't worry it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
according to the u.s census bureau
nearly one in ten
people relocated last year and that was
2020
when a lot of people weren't even moving
around that means this year there's a
good chance you
or someone you know is planning a big
move i know it feels like that there are
a thousand of
unknowns if you're struggling in
juggling
with relocating but you cannot lose
focus of one of the most important and
personal
and financial factors in your move your
housing cost i recommend hiring a
quality real estate agent like one of
our endorsed local providers to help you
find
the right home in your new city elps
are top performing experts in their
local market
and have years of experience helping
folks
just like you make successful moves
it's easy to get instantly connected
with an endorsed
local provider a high octane high
protein agent that knows their stuff to
help you
with the move go to ramseysolutions.com
agent and you can talk with a ramsey
trusted
agent about how they can help you with
your relocation ramseysolutions.com
agent our question of the day comes from
blinds.com
one of america's great success story
this company is
yeah you ought to check them out they
the number one online rela
retailer of custom window coverings i
have bought window blinds from them
i love these guys you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best
possible deal so dave uh today's
question comes from teresa in ohio she
says my husband
and i contributed monthly for our son
son in a state run 529 plan
plan he will be going to college in the
fall between the 529 plan and
scholarships
he's earned um he's earned we have
almost
enough to pay for all four of college
yay yeah i love it should we continue to
put money in this 529 plan until he
graduates college
our other options are putting the money
towards our daughter's 529 or paying
down our 30k
mortgage balance well i mean hey you
guys already have
his uh four years taken care of should
we continue to put money 529 plan until
he graduates
no no um should you go ahead and
continue
and put money towards your daughter's
529 absolutely yep
bottom line easy i mean honestly you can
do both put money towards 529
and pay down your mortgage at the same
time exactly depending on how much
you need what you need to do is figure
out what the target is for her 529
and are you on pace to be there if
you're on pace to be there maybe you
lean on the mortgage
absolutely or if you're behind maybe
you'll lean heavier on the files
on her 529 yeah way to go teresa
you did it i love it he paid for
college 529 and scholarships yep
this is what anthony o'neill teaches
simple it's it's
tuesday and you go to a school that
actually allows you to do that because
you can afford the school
yes you pick a school based on listen if
you got
20 000 to buy a car you don't need a
test drive for bentley
so you don't need to visit a college
campus that's 80 000 a year
if you're broke people why would you do
that
because when it comes to education
people lose their freaking minds
so we do they don't think anymore
they're not smart when it comes to
education
now that's an oxymoron sam is with us in
saint paul minnesota hi sam welcome to
the ramsay show
hey gentlemen thank you so much for
having me it's really an honor
appreciate everything you do
thank you how can we help so looking for
a little uh what would you guys do
question here is the first time in my
life earlier we got a letter from a
collections agency
saying that i have a three and a half
year old stupid red light ticket
and the more i investigate it the turns
out they were said they sent a citation
to
an old address that i haven't lived at
since college and um
my of course the thing has now you know
tripled in
how much i owe and uh how much is it
do you so right now it's at almost 400.
started out at 150 and how much do you
mind
i i make plenty i mean i make like 116
and my wife makes like 54. so we can
roll the thing over it's more of a
matter of principle
i mean anthony's had more traffic
violations than i have maybe he can tell
you
and man i was barely rolling through as
it turned red
hey man he gets that porsche gets it
going and
it's pulled over i'm telling you oh yeah
well this was a 2008 ford taurus so i
wasn't doing that trust me
yeah definitely not doing that in ford
hey man
honestly i mean just pay it man you got
the money
it's going to take you so much time to
fight it it's not going to really be
worth it bro i mean just
hang up the phone go pay the ticket call
it a wrap yeah all right we'll do it
it's hard to swallow thank you guys i i
don't blame you it's hard as well it's
not four thousand dollars though
yeah call it a day um yeah you're
fighting with the government
and they're incompetent and they know it
and you know it
and i know it the only thing that's
competent in this whole discussion was
the stinking red light camera it
actually was telling the truth
but um everything after that was not
nobody else in the whole story was
including
i got one of those one time yeah i got
knoxville they put them up in knoxville
and i was down there for a football game
and i roll a red light like
all the time i mean he can call him and
say hey listen i see this in collections
i have
i wasn't there i'll give i'll give you
half of it i'll give you two feet try
but
yeah it's probably not gonna work
exactly so it's nothing cause they got
you on that one i mean it's it's a
traffic ticket
right so so that was that's what you
usually do you just pay it
i mean you know
listen i gotta pull it over the other
day i
know i just pulled over before the cop
even killed me i'm guilty
give me give me the ticket you were
really guilty and he was really merciful
he didn't even give you a team
he didn't he sure didn't thank god turns
out he was a big anthony o'neill fan
yes lord i've been working hard to get
that you know
yes lord when he's i'm serious was he
was nice to you
yes all right bob pops in cincinnati
hey bob how are you hey dave how you
doing better than
anthony deserves what's up
so i got a question about how to utilize
or
best invest some extra cash that my wife
and i have
at the end of each month so currently
we pay off everything the only debt we
have is our house
we pay that off or should i say i
refinanced at the beginning of 2020
on that um and i paid two times the
monthly payments we did a 30-year loan
so i just double up the payments trying
to pay it off early
and so that said what we have at the at
the end of each
month about forty five hundred dollars
to invest uh we have three kids and we
have a utma
for each of them um we can max
contribute 15 000
um each year into those accounts and
then i have a traditional
ira that i put uh the remainder usually
about six thousand in each year
um and then on top of that my wife's
company has a 403 b
that she max contributes to and my
company also has a sep ira
that's typically uh it's about 15 to 20
annually are you putting 15 of your
household income into retirement
um no okay what is your household income
uh all in let's see
gross we're probably around
160. okay what we teach folks to do is
put 15
of their household income into
retirement at baby step four
beyond that fund your kids college what
you're doing
and beyond that put every extra dollar
towards the house until it is paid off
once it is paid off you max out
everything that's available to you and
you continue
investing at that point and that's what
we call baby step seven when the house
is paid off what do you owe on your home
about 257 okay you're gonna be done with
this house in no time with the numbers
you're giving me
and it's gonna be it's gonna be a
beautiful thing you're gonna have a paid
for home that's worth a lot of money
no payments in the world which guess
what we did then we just increased your
monthly cash flow
now you got even a bigger problem on
where you're gonna invest all this oh
darn i hate it when that happens
well all my kids are girls
so oh well there you go it won't hurt to
have some extra money laying around
because there's these uh you know you
may want weddings wedding funds
uh you know they're uh
they can they can be expensive if you
allow them to be
really like traffic tickets i'm just
saying they show up
and just uh there's there's all these
things in life that just happen
so you're doing so good bob way to go
man absolutely
killing it 15 of your income into
retirement then kids college
then pay off your house as fast as you
can then baby step seven is you build as
much wealth as fast as you can and be
outrageously generous
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free
stage open phones this hour here at
triple eight eight two five five
two two five on the debt free stage
first baptist church
mount dora florida pastor thomas and
sherry
jameson anthony also a former pastor
from
florida this church first baptist church
has become debt free
amen it certainly has
for you are you guys in town for the
southern baptist convention yes sir
all right wow y'all had a little little
ruckus down there
so you heard yeah i think yeah
well it's kind of it's kind of an every
year thing but some years the ruckuses
are bigger than others
but congratulations you got this paid
off how much debt did this church pay
off
well when i became pastor they had uh 2
million 889
000 in debt they were paying 8
interest on it yes and uh
it took three years for a bank to trust
the new pastor
to be able to refinance and even then it
was only
down to six percent wow they had 524
thousand dollars of that debt
in unsecured church notes to individuals
that could be called in at any time with
no penalty and so it really put the
church in a precarious position
my goodness gracious yeah so we we we've
refinanced over a four-year period when
i went the annual
or the monthly payment was 23
600 that was the every month
so uh the crash hit 12 months after i
had been there
of course my first sunday to preach on
money
was september the 9th of 2008 i remember
it well i'm preaching on money
and uh how we need to be good stewards
we're taking a special offering and the
banks have all luck
locked up great time for a special
offering wow so uh
we did three special offerings over
three months they collected over 153
000 wow uh and we put that directly on
the debt
and sherry and i as a sign of faith to
the lord we had been given wedding
money that we had put aside for 10 years
that we had kept kind of as our
emergency fund like what you talked
about
and we gave the church for this debt all
that we had in savings
wow and what i didn't know would be that
it would take us about
six years to save money again um
and personally we also forego we we did
not have any raises or anything for
eight years
we were really careful and trying to
make sure that the church could afford
staff
and and pay down the debt so when i went
there were 39 employees
so it was very very top-heavy and that
meant we had to
cut staff there was a preschool it was
running in the
in the hole we had to do away with the
preschool
it was a lot of hard decisions but you
were not a popular guy some weeks
if you only knew
i told the lady this morning nothing is
mean is a good mean christian
well that's that's really true we did we
did go through a
little i hate to say split splinter we
did have that in 2011
after i'd been there three and a half
years and then all the debt
uh notes which was over three hundred
and one thousand
were called in wow so uh
the church what we did is we managed but
we had about 35
i think left in our checking account
after we paid
all of that off and but it's gone
forever then exactly it was gone forever
he's got a strong leader he is
he's a strong leader he's still there
still there
14 years and uh and so
by the way we suspended all employee
benefits it sell
accept health insurance during this time
because our budget fell by 33 percent
from 08 to 2012.
it just it took a nosedive it was a very
construction-based
church with no doctors no lawyers
not even police and fire i just started
praying god give us people who earn a
salary we need teachers we need we need
we need uh doctors we need and so i've
baptized nine police officers
and uh we've seen the lord work through
the years so when you started at the
church how many years ago in 2007
how many people attended uh the day i
was voted on it was around 350 that
voted
i mean today uh well pre-corona we were
running we were running around 500 yeah
485 to 500 it's been as high as 5.50
and i've been through a ride to get
there yes sir yes
i'm so proud of y'all so well done we so
what what gave you this fire to get
the church's finances straightened out
that's not usually a pastoral gift
no no sometimes we have to encourage
pastors to do this
um my background was business actually
my my bachelor's was in business my
parents i was the first person in my
family to be called into ministry
okay and the first person in my church
in
uh almost 80 years to be called into
ministry
wow and there was a group of little old
ladies
who prayed every week since world war
ii that somebody would be called into
ministry so uh
the lord answered their prayer in 1989 i
surrendered
uh went into full-time christian service
served as a missionary
uh went to seminary at new orleans and
then after that did my phd in
at southwestern yeah and then uh went to
work for billy graham and worked for the
billy graham evangelistic association
and did that for several years and
traveled all over the country
and uh that's why there's a positives to
being young
and dumb so when i worked for mr graham
we would raise
five million in six months and i did all
of his largest crusades at the end
new york city and and los angeles and so
i thought
when i was young and dumb three million
wasn't that much
and so i thought we can pay this off in
18 months at this church
only billy graham's not around exactly
exactly so let me ask
an issue let me ask you this pastor
thomas what was throughout these 14
years
what was the hardest thing as a pastor
to get the church and the community on
board to be
intentional about paying off this debt
the hardest thing uh
constantly refocusing the vision that
this matters
it matters in missions and what we can
do in the community
uh we're very active in our community we
have been the largest
benevolence organization in mount dora
florida wow
a number of years where our giving in
the city is over eighty thousand dollars
that we're giving away wow um our
missions giving has been between
a hundred and two hundred and fifty
thousand at the same time we were paying
down debt and the buildings were all
falling apart at the same time so we had
to
replace all the roofs renovate the
preschool
we had to renovate the children's
building the youth building
all of these structures had to be
renovated
at the same time as paying down debt so
that was the challenge
one of our deacons who i love dearly
he's 92 years old
mr ray white is his name and mr ray
white would tell me
uh from time to time when he saw that i
was
wavering he'd look at me and he'd say
don't give up you can do this
he never told me what to do he was just
a faithful steward
so one of the things i did is i called
on other leaders how do we pay this off
and they said we'll do some dinners and
get all the people who give over a
hundred thousand in your church and i
started laughing
and they said well give all the get all
the people who give over 50 000 in your
church i
continue to like i said we don't have
those kind of people
in our church we don't you know i mean
to give 25 000 in a year so did you guys
have how did you get tied to us
uh how did we get tied to you well we've
taught financial peace
in our church for years we've got a
video of the congregation doing their
debt-free screening
yes i want to make sure we get that on
so proud of you guys thank you sir
thank you for this opportunity pastor
tom pastor jameson
thomas and sherry are with us from mount
dora florida first
baptist church paid off 100 of their dad
i talked to another church this morning
down in texas that just paid off these
24 million in debt they just cleared
theirs and
um but it's the same kind of story it
was a long slog
yes they fought through it but when the
bride of christ can get out of change
important things happens
amen so i'm so proud of y'all thank you
sir honored to know you guys
all right james let's fire that
[Applause]
a church debt free
[Applause]
yeah that is awesome any of you churches
that get debt free that you want to come
on and do that we'll we'll celebrate
with you i promise you we're proud of
you
good good stuff wow well done
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five you jump in and we'll talk
about your life and your money
josh is with us josh is in chicago how
are you josh
hi guys i'm doing great how about you
better than i deserve what's up
it's such an honor to be talking to you
guys you guys are both such role models
to me
so just to give you a little background
i'm 24 years old i'm in my third and
final year of
the doctor of physical therapy program
and basically i'm working my way through
cash flowing the program
my question is i've estimated about five
thousand dollars left from the
three semesters i have in my savings i
have about thirty three thousand dollars
and i have an additional twenty two
thousand dollars in
mutual funds and my question is am i
at a bit of a risk you know having a
possible change in tuition a little bit
i i maybe have like a four or five
thousand dollar margin
am i good to let those mutual funds
continue to grow
or do you think i should basically just
cash them out to ensure
that graduation well let me answer this
question is the mutual funds covered
with the roth ira
is it in retirement no there's not
retirement no it's just it's just
regular mutual funds not retirement
okay cool and you say you have 33 000 in
your savings account right now
correct i mean if i was you i mean and
you only need 25
about 25 i could see it i don't mind
leaving it in there because i don't
think they're going to go down that
substantially yeah if they did go right
me too so i mean right i'm sticking with
my savings account just a cash flow
through school
yeah use the savings account first and
if you need to dip into the mutual fund
you can
uh it might have dropped a little you
might lose a little but that's going to
be
still better than going into debt yeah
and and so but you're going to burn your
savings first and then dip into your
mutual fund
that's what you're saying absolutely yes
sir i just want to make sure that it
wasn't in retirement but yeah
use a savings account yeah don't cash
out a retirement account but
you shouldn't put in putting it in there
anyway until you're out of school so
well done good good i love it nicole is
with us nicole is in kansas city hi nico
whoops women not there
there she is hey nicole how are you good
how are you
better than i deserve what's up perfect
my question is my husband and i are in
baby step
two we have about 31 000
just in student loan debt and that's it
my husband does have one more year left
of law school
but he's smart so it's a full ride and
by the end of the summer with his
internship we should have
about that 32 000 saved up in savings
but since his payments are being
deferred for one more year should we
take that money that we have in savings
and just pay it off now since interest
starts back up in october
we're just not for sure kind of we've
just been saving for this
moment you know and since we'll have all
the money we just don't know what to do
so nicole let me get this straight your
husband has
um some scholarships getting him through
school 100 debt free right
correct is there anything that could
possibly come up
that can change that no at this point
just with his gpa
um he's set going into this final year
so he's been on a full ride
luckily all three years so and they
can't revoke that for any reason
correct okay and how are you paying for
the rest of your life
um off my income i make about 40 000 a
year
okay so you pay rent food and so forth
with that his school is paid for
locked for the last year done correct
yeah go ahead and pay it off exactly
okay
okay we just weren't for sure and we
just didn't know if
with payments being deferred and all
that here's what's gonna there's an
interesting thing that you haven't
thought of
and you're gonna be able to feel it just
by saying it when you pay this off
you're going to feel it
you're going to physically feel it right
right okay that's not a that's
that's a spiritual thing right right
yeah i just wanted some confirmation so
we're just
maybe we should maybe we'll hold on to
it until we can start making payments we
just didn't really know what to do now
nicole let me say this
if there is a one percent possibility
that something could
come up to where you will have to pay
something
then i want you to hold on to that money
to make
sure that you get through college
without racking up
any more debt if there's a one percent
now as soon as he graduates
you're gonna take all that money and put
it on top of the student loans but if
you know
a hundred and one percent that there's
no way that you all will need any more
money to graduate
then i'm working with dave go pay off
your student loans today
do not put yourself in any possible
position
where you have to borrow money to finish
law school right when you have the money
in your hand
and spent it on this yeah so don't do
that but
it sounds like that they've already made
the commitment and even if his gpa went
down
that he would get that this year is over
because they make the commitment one
year at a time they being the
law school yeah that's what it sounds
like to me so
hey good question and what a great job
he's done obviously he's a smart
cookie uh you know that kind of gpa in
law school enough to get
free money that's a good thing real good
that's a good thing and they said it's
impossible
tina is in saint petersburg florida hi
tina how are you
i mean gab how are you doing better than
i deserve what's up
well um i hope and y'all can help me
with a
problem that i have here i have a um a
200 000 uh vacation
property that is paid for at the cabin
on 13 acres
and um we also have a 225 000
mortgage on our primary home which we
also use as an airbnb
and i wanted to know if you think that
we should
take the investment property the cabin
on the acreage
and sell it to pay off the mortgage
that's our
airbnb i'm sorry i i is it your primary
residence or is it an airbnb how can it
be both
um we have some additional rooms that we
rent out
oh i see we live in part of the house i
see okay and what's your household
income
um we have about 93 000 take home per
year
okay so how quick do you pay off the
mortgage if you keep the lake house
if i can put everything into it keeping
my current
full-time job a little under four years
yeah you like the lake house
uh well i've only been up there once
and how long so uh um we've it's been a
little less than a year that we owned it
okay well i mean if you're not going to
use it
even if your home were paid for i
probably would sell it
but if you're going to use it and you
love it and you want to fight for it and
for scratching claw and grind for four
years and keep the thing and get your
mortgage paid off i'd be okay with that
too
yeah either one of those is an okay
process the trick is
that have a short-term plan to be
debt-free
and don't keep things that keep you in
debt that you don't even use
okay so i mean if you put those two
things together you get your answer out
of this
facts
also with that we we had thought about
purchasing an
additional duplex to have two more
airbnbs but
with um with what i've got going on
right now i wouldn't be able to do that
debt-free no no yeah no stay away
here's the problem some cities are
passing ordinances against airbnb
yeah and if they pass that as a zoning
violation in your area after you went in
debt to do it now you
just have two duplexes right
yeah and so um
because you're running a hotel is what
you're running yeah
some cities are objecting to that uh
from a zoning standpoint
and some neighbors are objecting to it
yeah as well
so um it you know it's it's not all
roses and rainbows with airbnb
so i you know i'm not saying it's
horrible a lot of people are making good
money on it but it you know to assume
that that is your business model long
term is probably not a good plan
yeah i agree i was looking into it dave
and i didn't do it too because of my
realtor
he said hey i don't trust the zoning uh
especially here in nashville knights
national pass to law against yeah yeah
yeah so now it's being challenged in
court right because you know
nashville tries to do a lot of communist
stuff huh but tell me about it
yeah we'll see what they get away with
or not but that's
you know they did they they flat out
shut it down
well there you go that puts us hour in
the books anthony good hour hey thank
you dave well done
james charles is our producer kelly
daniels our associate producer i'm dave
ramsey your host
and we'll be back
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host open phones
here as we talk about
america's largest legalized fraud
this hour time shares
oh i just got a little throw up in my
mouth when i said it
time shares if you've been ripped off or
locked in
one of those rooms or someone you love
has been ripped off by a timeshare
company
you know what that makes you typical
most people have it's a horrible
business
they have absolutely zero value you know
what a time share is worth when you try
to sell it
zero you actually have to pay to get rid
of it
and you go on vacation
and you're so cheap that you thought you
were gonna beat them up
and they say we'll give you a free hotel
room
if you will just come to the sales
presentation
and then they lock you in the sales
presentation with no food no water and
no bathroom breaks
for six hours literally does happen
until you surrender because your blood
sugar is so low that your brain quits
working and you buy
one of the dumbest things on the planet
called a time share
even going to one of those meetings is a
dumb thing
signing up to get a free hotel room that
isn't that great to start with
in return for giving up six hours of
your soul
is a dumb thing don't do that
that's like going over to the zoo and
they say we'll give you a year's pass
if you go into the cage with the tiger
and pet him for an hour oh by the way
he's not eaten in three days he's a
greedy animal
and he will chew on your head he will
likely not allow you to pet him
you will die and you go oh no for a free
pass to the zoo for a year i'll try
petting the tiger
because i can pull it off and you go in
and you come out without your arm and
then you're shocked
because the tiger ate your butt well
that's what happens
the aarp says the top 10
scams that cost older americans
the most money number one
way the elderly is scammed
romance scams 83 million dollars lost
last year
number seven out of the list of the ten
scams that take money from the elderly
according to the aarp
timeshares 17.4 million
number 10 trying to sell
the timeshare 12.5 million
which by the way together is 30 million
dollars that the elderly have been cost
last year
in late december diane burkhardt sent a
complaint to the fbi describing our 88
year old father agreed to purchase
250 000 worth of timeshare points over
the course of 18 months
he was diagnosed with dementia during
this time
he's now 89 and living in a nursing home
and the couple of course purchased the
points from
diamond resorts international one of the
grossest of all the timeshare companies
who has just been purchased or is in
agreement to be purchased by hilton
for 1.4 billion dollars
hilton you're getting ready to screw up
a really good brand by swallowing this
rat
i know you think you're swallowing this
rat but you're going to get indigestion
when you do hilton
it's going to cause you a problem as a
matter of fact there are activists
shareholders trying to prevent the sale
because they do not want
hilton to buy diamond resorts
her father 87 at the time enjoying a day
trip to the beach with his wife at a
town about 30 miles from their house
in central california and they came
across a charming hotel
unbeknownst to them the property was
hotel california no i'm kidding
it would you know you know you can leave
you can but you can't you can come in
but you really can't leave you know
been purchased by diamond salespeople
standing outside the property lured the
old interested couple into a timeshare
sales pitch
she writes that they immediately
regretted the purchase a month after
purchasing the first contract my
dad tried to end the agreement due to
his wife's declining health
and included a letter diamond turned him
down so he paid off the promissory note
in full believing that would be the end
of it
it was only the beginning shortly
thereafter diamond told them they needed
to go to a meeting to learn how to use
their points
the meeting turned out to be another
lengthy sales pitch
250 thousand dollars later
they owned a bunch of points to diamond
oh by the way he had dementia
turn it over to the fbi who's
investigating
it's not the first time consumers have
described possible elder abuse
in the timeshare industry which was
reinventing its business model in recent
years
yeah sales are down timeshares used to
be tied to a specific property where
people owned a partial deed
and had the right to vacation for a set
amount of days a year but in recent
years the industry has instead
switched over to the points concept just
kind of like those airline miles you get
with your credit card you ever tried to
use them dadgum near impossible
so if you've been screwed over by the
timeshare industry we want to hear from
you this hour
we're going to talk to real people we're
going to talk to attorneys who are suing
the timeshare industry
we're going to continue to expose this
fraud
in america today diamond international
being at the top of the list westgate
along in there and
when mo wyndham you have done some nasty
things to people
and uh we're going to be talking about
all of you guys this hour at length
things that actual real people are
saying about you
like the aarp or the fbi
these are initials that actually people
think might matter
when someone files a complaint against
you people because
you screw people for a living a time
share
is one of the worst possible products
out there
because it has zero value
zero none nada
horrible with what you spend on a time
you go pay 22 000 for a week how many
times can you stay in a freaking hotel
for 22 000
where is the math going did you people
go get out
unbelievable what grade did you graduate
from
but when you're sitting in the tiger
cage and the tiger's going come here i
won't eat you if you sign
come here come here pet the tiger go
into the tiger cage and pet the tiger
he's not eaten for three days they will
tell you anything
they will lie to you they will
be mean to you they will be nice to you
they will do
anything to get you to give you give
them
your money for something that has
absolutely no
value zero none nada
no value
so time share people we want to hear
from you the phone number is triple
eight
eight two five five two two five if
you're in the scummy business and you
wanna debate me
call in come into the tiger cage yeah
that would be good radio yeah and uh
maybe maybe you don't like me that's
fine come on we'll talk
i i don't like you either so it's a fair
trade yeah
you screw people for a living you should
stop it
oh my son's a timeshare salesman dave
you shouldn't talk nasty about him your
son should get a job where he doesn't
screw people for a living
he's scum don't be scum anymore and i
won't call you scum it's easy
[Music]
real easy don't rip people off and you
won't have me
on your back it's not a hard thing
phone number here is triple eight eight
two five five two two five
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
so if you have a background in the time
share industry or you
have been ripped off by them or you want
to talk about
the business because from a personal
experience we want to hear from you the
phone number is triple eight eight
two five five 5225
you can also email kelly and put
timeshare in the subject line and tell
us a little bit about your story and
we'll get back in touch with you and put
you on a future
show on timeshares because this won't be
the only time we
talk about america's greatest
legalized fraud so you can email kelly
at dave
on air at ramseysolutions.com daveonair
ramseysolutions.com put time share in
the subject line tell us a little bit
about it and give us a place for kelly
to get back in touch with you
we're not going to tell you what to say
but we just want to arrange for you to
be on the air
and tell your story to 22 million people
yeah you should we want to hear from you
dave on air at ramseysolutions.com
ben is in chicago hi ben what happened
with you
oh i've had quite a journey uh with the
timeshare industry and
and actually with you as well i went to
get my master's
about seven years ago and one of my
professors made us study
this book you may have heard of it total
money makeover
and uh so my wife and i actually began
to live out those steps
very laser focused because our goal was
to not have kids until we
were debt-free we accomplished that goal
and then once we had kids our laser
focused
from fatigue or whatever went away and
uh
had made a couple questionable choices
one of them happened in february we
hadn't taken a vacation just her and i
together for a long long time so went
down to florida
i'm naturally relatively frugal and so
uh just got signed up for a time share
presentation and
in hopes that we could see some free sea
world
and so went down there and had you
didn't even get a free night you got
tickets to see to sea
world to see yep exactly wow
exactly so we went down there and this
is this past year so february 11th we
showed up
as far as the comedies that is fine you
know nothing overly special but it's
fine
did that for three days and finally the
timeshare presentation
came around it was early in the morning
on valentine's day
sunday morning and so we went down there
early
got pulled into a room had a one-on-one
experience
with the sales person and they start
asking you personal questions about
yourself because they're trying to
find what they can poke what they can
manipulate right what your soft spots
are
and like i said for me it's my kids
and so they poked in pride until they
found that and uh basically the sales
pitch was
well you want to have your kids have a
great experience right
you want them to have regular vacations
right you want them to
grow closer to you this is how you do it
you can do it in an affordable way
since i do have a background with you in
the past but i
hadn't recently been walking that line
well i knew timeshare was not ideal
so i said look i don't want to be in a
contract
i don't want to pay an xx amount it's
got to be
it's got to be a deal and so he said
well we are the only
time share company that offers a full
buy-back guarantee so if you don't like
it
whenever this happens you sell it back
it will be
market retail you know you're gonna
you're gonna have at least as much as
you paid for it if not
more and so that was appealing right
it's a get out of jail free card if we
hated it
and he gave us points and so he said
your stay
is 40 000 points and i said well what is
that worth right it means nothing until
you have some time on it
he said offered to stay here in a silver
lake resort which is in
kissimmee florida he said that that was
worth three weeks
and i said okay did the math
we did a down payment
of five thousand zero percent interest
for the rest of it which is ten thousand
total i've done the math obviously on
that three weeks
in orlando and they said or anywhere
else
uh it was a fairly reasonable deal
and so we walked out we felt pretty
comfortable with it
but everything we found out very quickly
was fraudulent
so 11 days out which of course is one
day after the contract they finally give
us the login information
no points there i call in and they say
well you've got to wait we'll insert the
points for you
and the process goes on and finally in
april
and may we have access to our points and
so i try to punch them in
to test their value because i'm starting
to feel pretty concerned about this at
this point in time
and i realized that forty thousand and
not only just forty thousand but they
gave us a bonus
twelve thousand points on top wasn't
worth three weeks in fact it wasn't
worth
one week of a stay at this resort
and so i called back in and said this is
a fraudulent sales practices i don't
want to be a part of this
and so i'm going to evoke the buy back
guarantee and they said we don't offer
such a thing
so of course this drove me through
all sorts of things including reading
every word of the contract and of course
built into the contract
is this tiny little phrase we are not
held accountable to anything the
salesman
says and so we
went through that process uh try to get
a hold of them
back and forth no response no response
no response no response
right in the middle of that of course in
my stress and distress
you did this hour-long time share
presentation talk
which made me feel much much worse
about the situation i'm sorry and i
reached
no it's okay it was just the reality
right it was true yeah
so which company is this uh
the the resort is called silver lake
resorts in kissimmee florida
i don't know the affiliation i know
you've talked about some of these bigger
entities
but i i'm not entirely sure of
whatever their affiliation is but since
then
i've contacted the better business
bureau of course all they do is say
do bad we've contacted them they refuse
to work with you they refuse to work
with you they refuse to work with you
we'll just put a bad review on their
page
which doesn't help me at all so right
now i'm
stuck with something i don't want based
on
two aggressive lies when i finally got a
hold of somebody of course they said
well
we can't do anything for you and and the
guy who sold that to you of course
doesn't work here anymore of course
which i wish i'm assuming is just a a
quick
yeah no they don't because they know
they're screwing people and they go get
a job where they don't have to do that
anymore
because most people have somewhat of a
soul
you know most people do but uh so i'm
trying to look up silver oak on google
while we're doing this james you keep
poking around
it looks like it's independent rci
resort directory i don't know what rci
is
but uh yeah so but anyway we know we
know that that's
one but this is standard i mean this is
standard for all this
this this story could have been logged
under any
uh you know any of the companies that
are out there
because this is this is exactly what
happens with every one of them
and so but this one is uh whatever rci
is apparently they're affiliated with
that so
very interesting wow i'm so sorry ben
sorry you got screwed but thank you for
telling the story because that lets
people know that this really happens all
the time
so really what we're saying is you can
tell a timeshare
salesman is lying if his mouth is moving
that's what you experienced accurate and
i you know after your
long presentation about this i was
really embarrassed
and i haven't want to tell anyone about
it but i thought you know what
scripture is filled with these guys who
make mistakes and it's from their
mistakes that we
actually grow from it so i thought you
know what i'm embarrassed about this
i don't want to tell people about this i
don't want to tell my neighbor about
this
but people need to know i appreciate you
i appreciate you pushing through that
when i went broke and lost everything i
was
embarrassed to tell anybody about it for
a long time and now i've helped a whole
lot of people because i told the story
so all it makes you if you got messed
over by these people is human dude you
got nothing to be embarrassed about they
lied to you
as you said it was a fraudulent
transaction
and now we just let the world know
silver lake
resorts kissimmee florida gosh i
wouldn't want to be them this week would
you
can you imagine what happened i just
said that over the radio
with 22 million listeners can you
imagine
working there tomorrow
[Music]
the largest legalized fraud in america
today the timeshare industry
billions upon billions upon billions of
dollars
one of the largest diamond international
being sold right now to hilton for 1.4
billion dollars
mike flasky the ceo mikey i call him
mikey is obviously as the ceo's holding
a bunch of
stock in his hand that's getting ready
to be converted to hilton stock
this guy's getting ready to get richer
than he already is with his sale to
hilton
activist investors are fighting the
hilton
stockholders of hilton are fighting
against this sale
saying it's bad for hilton well guess
what it is
when you swallow a whole wheelbarrow
load of rats
you know what you're going to get hilton
indigestion
your brand is going to get screwed up
because you're associated with people
screwing people
westgate all this bunch westgate resorts
according to this article westgate
resorts class action alleges high
pressure sales tactics uses high
pressure schemes
to convince prospective purchasers in
the buying vacation
timeshare program according to legal
news a recent class-action lawsuit
alleges westgate failed to adequately
disclose material and legally required
information to prospective buyers and
also doesn't provide
adequate access to their time shares
there it is again
in addition the timeshare owners claim
westgate fails to
adequately train and supervise its sales
agents
and does not provide them with
disclosures to give to prospective
customers and encourages them to lie
to customers with high pressure sales
pitches westgate also
also allegedly relies on its closing
agents to provide written disclosures
and provides them with a closing
portfolio
that contains a secret pocket
where the closing officers can conceal
legally required disclosures about the
consumer's rights
including their right to rescind the
purchase
scummy scummy
uh randy's in madison wisconsin
got a time share story what's up randy
hey dave uh my story's not unique
probably to
anything that you guys have already
discussed or anything but
i just kind of wanted to share and just
kind of warn people
about what you're talking about and uh
it kind of relates to what you say about
credit cards
you're just playing with snakes and if
you get in that snake pit with them
eventually you're going to get bit so
don't even give them the opportunity to
bite you because that's what they're
really trying to do is lure into that
pit and fill you full of their venom
it's like when we went and did it
i think they really truly try to prey on
poor people the most because if you if
you've got
money you you're really not there trying
to seek a good deal on a vacation you
just go on vacation
you get the hotel room you book you get
the flights and you go but they try to
who i think prey on the people that
they're
we're trying to reel in by well we can
sell them this great
deal even though they might not be able
to afford it be the only way they can go
on vacation
what happened well in our scenario
it was we were just newly married
and we were we were thinking about you
know vacations you know heck we got 40
50 years hopefully together and
what do we want to do for vacations you
know we got this thing in the mail
you know say come join us you know
basically feed you for the you know give
you that free meal
and uh lure you into a casino night
where you could win
gifts and uh and then they they lure you
into the room by themselves and they
give you the sales pitch and
they they all you know just like
everyone else has said the pressure
the tactics that they use the promises
they give you
but even some more the stuff that they
don't tell you
we weren't told about numerous things
whether it be the
rca subscription that you had to use to
buy every year
whether it was the exchange fee that you
had to pay if you wanted to go outside
your week
you know and and we borrowed money you
know like you say you know the
borrower's slave to the lender
i walked out of that meeting that night
with them guys and you know they
they bring it in with the one guy and
then you know they they got the guy in
the back who can make you a better deal
you know what i mean oh yeah and i i
walked out of there that night me and my
wife sick to our
stomach as soon as we got in the car and
left that after we signed on the dotted
line we were sick to our stomach
what did we just do well little did we
know we had a writer rescission we knew
nothing about that because we weren't
educated in it they didn't let us in on
any of that you know that we could have
got out of it
you know when we got home the next day
but we were reeled in
and um with all the promises and uh
which company
well and dave i don't know who that was
um it was um
up at the wisconsin dells outside of
madison
and it was at christmas mountain village
is the name of the resort but it might
have been like winter tree or winter
green
or something like that i can't really
remember bluegrass um
oh that okay that could have been what
it was but um
and i mean and i know people they have
that
own three of these things and they don't
ever leave their yard can you imagine
that
i mean you're talking four or five
thousand dollars and
you're not even going on vacation but
you own three of them oh
boy i to talk about a sucker one sucker
twice but
um so we were blessed dave unlike the
gentleman that you just had on before me
in wisconsin um we contacted the better
business bureau
and the consumer protection agency and
they actually filed a class action
lawsuit
on our behalf and we
we did not pay a dime to get out of it
and they won the lawsuit
and they agreed to let us out of the
deal and
give us our money back wow praise god
yeah you got it you got out with your
skin but other than that it's the same
story
it's the same story i mean don't even
give them the opportunity because just
don't go in the tiger cage don't pet the
tiger
you think you're stronger than the tiger
but when you get in the cage you realize
you're not
yeah don't pet the tiger why pet the
tiger just for just for a pass to the
zoo
it's silly that's what that's what
everybody does hey man thanks for the
call i appreciate you sharing that
hey if you've got a time share story
call us at triple eight eight two five
five two two five or email me at dave on
air
at ramsey solutions dot com dave on air
ramsey solutions dot com
put time share in the subject line tell
kelly who be picking up those emails a
little bit about what's going on and how
to get in touch with you
we certainly won't tell you what to say
but we will schedule you
to be on the air scott montgomery is a
an attorney who frequently sues the
timeshare industry he's in springfield
missouri we thought we'd have scott on
because he's got some expertise in this
area
how are you scott i'm great dave how are
you
i am better than i deserve sir and uh
that's confirmed by mike flasky
wow so tell me uh
he thinks i deserve a lot worse in other
words
so tell me your experience with this
industry
well back in 2018 we
filed lawsuits here in missouri uh near
branson missouri which is a
a beautiful part of the country but
certainly a cesspool
of timeshare activity so we were hired
by
dozens of mostly elderly timeshare
owners
and we filed lawsuits on their behalf
and in retaliation for that
windham and bluegreen sued me personally
down in florida where i have never
practiced
law and i'm still mired in those
lawsuits today
the the discovery seems to be never
ending
and you know these lawsuits against
attorneys like me who represent
defrauded timeshare owners they're
clearly designed
to chill access to the courts or these
defrauded owners it's it's really
horrible
one of the timeshare pushers attorneys
actually said in court that their goal
is to put
fake law firms out of business they they
call mine a fake law firm
you know we're a small law firm of poor
attorneys here in the missouri
ozarks but we're far from a fake law
firm and we've filed lots of lawsuits
against the timeshare industry
in the suit that they filed against us
down in florida
they actually complained that we have
not sued them
enough so we we have tried to oblige
them
and sue them some more
[Laughter]
that's fabulous oh can you hang with me
through this break scott
i sure can okay i'll be right back with
you i want to hear the rest of this
so we oblige them and suit them some
more
i like this guy this is fun oh we're
talking about time shares this hour if
you want to join the discussion the
phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today psalm 62 and 5 let
all that i
am wait quietly before god for my hope
is in him
amelia earhart said decide whether or
not the goal is worth the risks involved
if it is stop worrying well our goal
today is to continue to expose
and continue to discuss the timeshare
industry
the american association of whatever
having to do with the timeshare business
is called arda
and they funded a report that says that
87 percent of time share owners rate
their timeshare ownership
as good or excellent funded by the
timeshare industry
uh however university of central florida
did a study that says just the opposite
eighty-five percent of time sharing
owners who go to contract
regret their purchase how many
businesses
do 85 of their customers think they suck
and they stay open how many
unbelievable all right we're talking
with an attorney in missouri scott
montgomery who was uh
on behalf of elderly people ripped off
in the ozarks with time shares it sued
several companies
their answer was to sue him to sue the
attorney
and since they're a small law firm to go
ahead and just bury them
in discovery requests
buckets and failings of discovery
requests
to see if they can put these attorneys
out of business their goal
is to put these attorneys that sue them
out of business by
countersuing them or suing them and
burying
them scott that's what you said right
absolutely dave that's what's happening
now christian wall was on here a few
weeks ago another attorney who's
representing
attorneys who have been sued and is he
representing you too
yes he is dave oh good good sharp very
good
so you guys are kind of banding together
to fight back
we are absolutely we're trying to
gather together good litigators from
around the country to
combat this problem and you know our
firm we
we represent almost 7 000 time share
owners from around
the country and i would say that 100
percent of my thousands of clients
think that the timeshare industry sucks
and they hate their timeshare
and regret their purchase tremendously
yeah so that's an unofficial survey
right there
but fairly accurate yeah if you if you
hire an attorney to sue somebody you
pretty much think they suck i think that
that's 100 yeah i'll go with that
that's fun so the cause of action from a
legal perspective that you guys usually
take if you're going to sue someone you
can't just make up something to sue them
about
unless you're the timeshare business
which they made up something to sue you
about but
you guys are finding actual fraudulent
processes that you're
putting in the case i assume
absolutely dave we we sue for fraud
and for negligent misrepresentation and
for violations of state merchandising
practices
act which allows our clients to
recover their damages along with their
attorney's fees
but we we've also started filing
lawsuits
based upon some more innovative causes
of action
i think one is for the charging of
illegal document preparation
fees if you if you go to a closing at
your timeshare sales presentation
you're probably going to be stuck with
hundreds or thousands of dollars of
illegal document preparation fees that
uh
that constitutes the unauthorized
practice of law that
that's a crime a non-attorney cannot
charge
for document preparation fees we're also
seeing the tactics where the timeshare
pushing companies
they charge their uh they charge the
consumer
for title insurance title insurance
for these points you don't get
create it if you don't get a title how
can you get title insurance
it is certainly a mystery to me but they
charge hundreds or thousands of dollars
for title insurance for points that they
created
it's just crazy we we have seen a large
time share pusher
charge uh thousands of dollars for a
life insurance policy
so that the consumer can you know be
sure and pay off their debt to the
timeshare company
when uh when they pass away
we've also filed suit for the
unauthorized practice of realty you know
these
shares there and they're an interest in
real estate
and the seller and the agent that have a
real estate license
yeah the guy who's sitting across the
table from you at the timeshare sales
presentation
they should have a realtor's license and
they don't
so we're filing suits on on the basis of
all of those things yeah and how often
are you getting them out these days
well that's a that's a great question it
depends on the
individual circumstances of the
individual case
yeah there are hundreds of time share
pushers in the country
but you got you said you had 7 000 cases
underway right
we have almost 7 000 clients currently
or who we have have helped to obtain a
release
oh i've asked okay we've helped
thousands of people
obtain a release it is unfortunately it
is uh much easier
for you to get out of your timeshare
contract if you are what is known in the
industry as
paid in full if you paid off your
timeshare mortgage
and that's a thing most timeshare
purchases are financed
if you've paid off your mortgage and
you've paid your
annual maintenance fees which are often
fifteen hundred dollars for something
you can't use
if you're paid in full we can often
negotiate
a release for you from the timeshare
pushing
company yeah if you still have if you
still have a mortgage it's much more
difficult
they don't want to give up that money
they've already but if they already got
your money they're more likely to let
you go yeah that makes sense
oh my gosh hey scott we appreciate you
sharing with us today man
that's incredible i'm so sorry they're
going after you personally that's just
ridiculous but it's uh
it's par for the course with these guys
they think they have enough money to
just bury
anybody who takes them on and uh well
now they've met somebody that's not
gonna happen
james is with us james is in waco texas
hey james how are you
i'm doing fine dave how are you good
give me a quick version
of your timeshare mess okay basically uh
back in uh march of 99 my wife and i
i went on a honeymoon in las vegas and
uh
we were hanging around the hotel and guy
came up to us and was talking to us
about
uh a show that they were giving free
tickets to that night if we
wanted to come and listen to a
presentation the next day
so we did that and uh make a long story
short we ended up listening to the
presentation
and we purchased the timeshare phone and
uh we uh had the time share for about 15
years and
only use them five times
[Music]
okay so you paid three thousand dollars
per use
yeah and so
yeah and so uh was it worth that
i mean did you no no no i mean what
could you bought a hotel room that was
similar to that for
oh my goodness probably 120
at the moment back then anyway yeah yeah
per night
yeah yeah okay 10. right yeah
wow amazing which company was this
i was uh diamond um diamond
international
international
okay so what ended up happening at the
end of the story
well basically uh we uh went to
um uh branson for another vacation
and and the hotel had the same guys
there from diamond resorts
they were pushing you know these
timeshares and
i told the guy we were already
remembering the timeshare so they looked
us up
and said hey you know you guys under the
old program
uh that's why you have to pay all these
maintenance fees but if you
sign up for a new program you don't have
to pay the maintenance fees
and of course you know we're already
listening to your show and we're trying
to figure out what to do about all that
oh my gosh i'm sorry james
so our answer is if you've been screwed
and you complain about it we'll sell you
some more
what a business 85 to 87
of your customers hate you and you still
stay in business that's amazing
well maybe we can help with that that
puts this hour of the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace
and that's to walk daily with the
friends of peace christ jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you